- My name is Peter Brooks,
and I just wanna say two minutes worth
of introduction to this conference.
The questions that we come
together to discuss today
very often grew out of the
experience of prison teaching
for me and for many of
the others who are here.
In my case, of course, I taught
at East Jersey State Prison
in Rahway, New Jersey, a few years ago,
which was for me an absolutely
transformative experience.
To experience as an outsider
the reality of the inside of prison
and the way it has affected
so many lives in our country
is to confront directly the way we
as a society, as a country,
have created the monster
of mass incarceration.
How has this shaped inner life,
public spectacle, moral possibilities?
What needs to be thought and
said about incarceration?
What do the literature
and art of incarceration
and of the incarcerated have to say to us?
How does incarceration haunt
even those outside of prison walls?
What are the stakes of the
prison education movement?
These are all questions,
or among the questions
that we're gonna think about here.
Since I teach literature,
I began to think about the
place and image of prison
in the public mind and in
works of literature and art,
going back at least to the Enlightenment,
especially to the work
of Cesare de Beccaria,
who published his "On Crimes
and Punishments" in 1764,
if you will, the the very beginning
of the prison reform movement.
And of other poets, novelist, dramatists,
artists, composers, who have
meditated on incarceration
and the human mind.
I think of Stendhal, Silvio
Pellico, Alexander Dumas,
Dickens, Victor Hugo, Dostoevsky, Gramsci,
and also Beethoven in
his one opera, "Fidelio."
The French Revolution, you remember,
kicks off with an attack
on an infamous prison, the Bastille,
which then symbolically is
demolished stoned by stone.
I think prison has become
the punitive shadow
to all the major
institutions of our society.
We live in that shadow,
but we also possibly
believe in the promise,
as one of my students
at East Jersey put it,
of churning prison into a university,
a grand aspiration
towards the transformation
of the carceral space
this country has created
into a place of learning and creativity
that brings us together today.
At least that is the hope
So we're gonna move at
once to the first panel,
but before I do that,
I wanna just speak a quick word of thanks
to those who have brought
this symposium into being.
It was originally to have
been at the Eric Holder Center
at Columbia Law School
two and a half years ago.
It was canceled because of COVID.
It was planned along with my good friends,
Bernard Harcourt, who is here today,
and Matthew Spellberg,
who is in Alaska and
couldn't be here today.
Transferred to Yale,
the symposium happily
found new collaborators.
Richard Weisberg and the Law
and Humanities Foundation
that he directs,
Judith Resnick and the Arthur Lyman Center
for Public Interest Law
that she created at the Yale Law School,
and Dwayne Betts and his
Freedom Reads program,
and the Whitney Humanities Center
where it found his present home
thanks to Alice Kaplan, the Director,
and Diane Brown, the Assistant Director,
and their remarkable staff,
including Megan O'Donnell
and a number of others.
So thanks said, and that's
really a small thanks
for the great work that
they've done in this.
I'm gonna turn things
over to Emily Bazelon,
who's too well known to you
all to need introduction.
Among her many honors and
attributes, fortunately for us,
she's a lecturer and
senior research fellow
at the Yale Law School.
Emily.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
Thanks so much, Peter.
It is such a pleasure to
be here with all of you
for this long anticipated exciting event,
which has so much interdisciplinary
richness to offer.
I'm really excited for,
to do a lot of listening
and maybe just a little bit
of talking this morning.
- Is this on?
- I don't know, is this working?
They're all on, okay, good, thank you.
That's okay, thanks, Rachel.
So I'm here with an
amazing panel of people
who bring just a real
variety of perspectives
to this topic of
incarceration and imagination
in a multi-genre way.
Rachel Kushner, who is sitting
to my right, is a novelist.
Her novels are "Telex from Cuba,"
"The Flame Throwers," "The Mars Room."
I have read these books
with great pleasure,
and partly agreed to
participate in this today
because I was so excited to meet Rachel.
I really recommend them.
And she has a book of essays
called "The Hard Crowd,"
and is a contributor to "The New Yorker,"
"The New York Times Magazine,"
and a columnist for "Harper's."
Caleb Smith is a professor
of English and American Studies at Yale.
And his books that are especially relevant
to today's discussion
are "The Prison and the
American Imagination,"
and an edition of Austin Reed's
"Life of the Adventures
of a Haunted Convict."
And Joy James, who is further to my right,
is the Ebenezer Fitch
Professor of Humanities
at Williams College,
and the editor of four anthologies
about political prisoners
and political activists.
So I'm delighted to be here
with this fabulous group.
And as you can tell, we're
spanning a number of genres here.
This is a group that represents fiction,
thinking about the prison as a space
in which to create fiction.
That is obviously like a
choice that Rachel made
in her third book.
A choice about setting
that I'm really eager
to hear more about.
And Caleb has written nonfiction,
and then thought a lot
about first-person accounts
and narratives from people
who are incarcerated,
which he will talk about more.
And Joy has this perspective
of people who are activists,
both within and outside of prison
and will be the respondent on the panel.
So Rachel, I was hoping that
you would talk a little bit
about what you think fiction is doing
in this space of incarceration.
Is it about witnessing?
And if so, how does it differ?
What can it offer that's
different from nonfiction
or kind of first-person
accounts of life in prison,
which are of course really important,
and we have people in this room today
who have those perspectives to offer.
And I'm really interested in how you think
the genre of fiction can compliment
some of the other writing and work and art
we have in this area.
So can I turn that over
to you with that question?
- Yeah, should we share this?
I don't know.
- [Caleb] Sure, you can use it first.
- All right.
It's like a math problem.
We have four people and three microphones.
(clearing throat)
Each person gets a microphone
for 1.33% of the time.
Well, I wrote a little paper.
Should I just read my paper
or should I answer that question?
- [Emily] Well, you can read your paper
and hopefully the answers
will emerge at some point.
We have a while so it's cool.
- I think that, I think that
what I brought to present
to you all here today
very much speaks to exactly the points
that you just brought up.
- [Emily] Good.
- should I just go for it?
- [Emily] Yes.
- Okay, it's 9:20.
(chuckling)
I think these are supposed to be
like 10 to 12 minutes, correct?
- [Emily] Yes.
All right. (clearing throat)
When I was working on my
novel "The Mars Room,"
I asked a friend who had
spent 23 years in the prison
on which I modeled my fictional one
if women on death row there worked jobs.
"They work," she said.
"They have six sewing machines."
"What do they sew?" I asked.
"Sandbags," she said,
"for the California
Department of Transportation."
Hearing this, an image
flashed into my thoughts
of an industrial axle turning and turning
as if I had suddenly been exposed
to the boiler room of the world,
or rather of California,
which might as well be the
world with its 40 million.
After that conversation,
every time I saw a sandbag
on the side of the highway,
I felt the turn of this axle
and I pictured women
running synthetic fabric
along the presser foot of a
state-supplied sewing machine.
These sandbags, which are
everywhere when you start to look,
remain for me a potent
symbol that the penal system
is floating all over the place.
After I wrote "The Mars Room,"
there was a question
people sometimes asked
that I did not like,
"Why didn't you write a
nonfiction book about this?"
I responded mostly by asking, in turn,
"Is not the novel a parallel universe
where we can glimpse and
understand aspects of this one?"
I think it's no accident
that this symposium
was conceived by someone who
has given so much thought
to the work of Balzac.
That's Peter Brooks.
Balzac's novels stand as a kind of zenith
of what the 19th century novel can do,
namely report on social reality
in both its fine grain detail
and in its sweep and structures.
Marx and Engels famously turned to Balzac
for what his novels
revealed about capital.
Entire chapters of Thomas Piketty's
"Capital in the 21st Century"
rely on Balzac novels
for their illumination
of wealth distribution.
As Peter Brooks notes, Balzac strove
to rival the civil registry
in his determination to people
his world so thoroughly,
from bankers to peasants to poets
to the figure, of course,
of the criminal male
whose cunning is to find
shortcuts to wealth.
Women might be tragic, but only men
like Balzac's infamous anti-hero,
Vautrin, can transgress.
The shadow of the criminal in literature
and also movies is long.
It stretches from the 19th
century into the mid 20th
with figures like Andy
Griffith's character
in "A Face in the Crowd"
discovered in a local jail
who rises to demonic heights
as a Donald Trump-like peddler of serums.
Cool Hand Luke's failure to communicate
with a Florida prison warden,
and Norman Mailer's
version of Gary Gilmore
in the "Executioner's Song."
By 1981, when imprisoned writer
Jack Henry Abbott's letters
to Norman Mailer were published
as the book "In the Belly of the Beast,"
this shadow was, I would argue,
overtaken by a more
engulfing set of shadows-
the ones cast by institutions,
the punitive turn in the
parlance of our symposium prompt.
The reformatory and prisons
that had shaped Jack Henry Abbott
left such a mark on him that
he was free only six weeks
before he stabbed and killed someone.
Six weeks after that
tragic turn of events,
Michiko Kakutani, then the most powerful
literary critic in America,
condemned Norman Mailer in
a "New York Times" article
titled "The Strange Case of
the Writer and the Criminal."
Kakutani summarized Jack Henry
Abbott's long incarceration
and short, brutal freedom.
She blamed Norman Mailer for
the stabbing of the victim,
a young actor named Richard Adan.
She talked about Mailer's
obsession with violence
and suggested that writers can
only ever play with violence
and that such play brings consequences.
Kakutani's argument relies on the idea
that the criminal is a social type,
a member, if you will,
of Balzac's registry.
She's unaware and unwilling
to grasp what prison,
even already by 1981,
had become in America-
a way to manage social
problems and inequality.
Prisons draw, as we all know,
from only one layer of society.
Fate of origin and not just destiny
do inform character in life and in novels.
But Kakutani suggests that
Jack Henry Abbott's problem
is that he isn't a reasonable man.
That's the term she uses.
Her article is fascinating to me
because it is such a transparent attempt
to exhaustively close a chapter
of American literary history,
one in which, as she sees it,
writers believe there is a moral symbolism
in crime and punishment.
But it is Kakutani's
argument itself that is...
Wouldn't it be funny
if she was here today?
But it is Kakutani's argument itself
that is foreclosed and moribund.
By 1981, the United States has embarked
on a prison building project
of breathtaking scope and reach.
By then, literary meaning
lies not in the figure
of the so-called criminal,
but in the institutions
that shape this person.
To say something true
about a modern day Vautrin,
the novelist must perceive and understand
the institutions that overshadow him.
An interesting echo of Balzac's ambition
to rival the civil registry
can be found in Michel Foucault's hope
to rival a registry of internment
dating from the 18th century
that he came upon in the
Bibliotechque Nationale.
Foucault planned to write a book
inspired by the brief
descriptions of imprisoned people
in this registry.
His book would be titled
"The Life of Infamous Men."
He described the feeling he got
upon reading brief and fragmented accounts
of people whose stories
suddenly rose up for him
through two and a half
centuries of silence.
What Foucault aimed to do
was to restore the intensity
of these obscure and
unknown people's lives.
Lives, as he put it, reduced to ashes
in the curt tone of a public ledger book.
Foucault describes them as cobbler's,
deserting soldiers, vagabond, monks.
"All these people might have
stayed in the dark," he says,
"were it not for the light of power
that shown down on them."
Their moment in court, in prison,
in this registry he holds in his hands.
To write about a prison
is perhaps not unlike
writing about a school, the
culture of a sea vessel,
a hospital or any other
self-enclosed world.
In this sense, I see a thread
connecting Melville's "Moby Dick"
to Kesey's "One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest"
and John Cheever's "Falconer."
But much of what sustains a
prison happens outside a prison.
The penal system, as I said,
is floating everywhere,
seen or unseen depending.
The writer may have been ensnared in it
and recount from personal
experience, as many have.
I never was, but I grew
up with people who were.
Kids whose fathers happened
to be police officers
while these kids all had a parole officer.
Their mothers worked
at bail bonds companies
or as court clerks downtown.
Now I live in Los Angeles,
the nation's most populous county.
My home is walking distance
from our criminal court complex.
A mile to the east is our jail complex.
What I write as fiction
cannot keep out what I see.
I cannot help but notice
who goes to court, to jail,
and who works in these places.
This is the world in
which Balzac's Vautrin
now finds himself-
Los Angeles, manufacturing
capital of the US
and a place of extreme wealth inequality.
A city that spends half of its
operating budget on police.
Vautrin's job prospects
might be a sorting warehouse
in the Inland Empire,
or something higher paying and less legal.
He might be the descendant
of people who came west
from Texas and Louisiana
to work unskilled jobs in
the aerospace industry.
Jobs that have long vanished.
This new Vautrin is possibly
acquainted with foster care,
youth authority, and family court.
He might try to find a shortcut to wealth
or a more modestly survival,
but in a modern novel,
he is not counseling Balzac's Rastignac
on marrying rich ladies.
He is boarding a sheriff's department bus
along with 60 other men and
heading for Cocoran Prison
deep in the heart of industrial farmland
where 6,000 others stand around
on level four housing yards
overseen by guards for whom prisons
are one of the biggest
employers in their rural county.
Corcoran is surrounded
by irrigation canals
through which subsidized water flows,
water used to grow almonds
that are exported all over the world.
A crop that is largely automated,
and thus jobs in prisons
rather than farming.
In order to understand
the life of this Vautrin,
the author of the novel
who casts him in a role
will want to have some
sense of cycles of drought
and economic recession and state capacity.
She'll wanna know how hot
it is on a level four yard
at Salinas Valley or Chowchilla or Chino.
She'll wanna have glimpsed
the circular logic
of California prison industries
where they make pews for juries
who decide the fate of people like them.
About her Vautrin, the novelist
will wanna have a sense
of the racial and class
barriers he has faced,
and of how and why her
character might decide
catastrophically and probably quickly
that violence could be a
solution to his problems.
This is a modern Vautrin
in modern California.
He has come a long way
from a Balzac novel,
and he might even be a woman,
which is how I wrote her in my attempt
to depict in my novel "The Mars Room"
the life of someone put on a bus to prison
in the Central Valley.
I wanna close by coming back
to this question people have asked me,
"Why not write a nonfiction
book about this stuff?"
The question isn't really a question.
It's a suggestion that one
should be doing activism
or at the very least,
journalism instead of writing novels
if you're gonna bother people
with such quote/unquote unpleasantness.
Foucault proposed project
of converting the internment
registry into narratives
anticipated this very reaction.
It is in the infamous of his
title, "Lives of Infamous Men,"
an adjective adding a promise of the lurid
and the sensational, which
I interpret as irony.
The real life outlaw,
even now 300 years ago,
was already buried under the
shadow of the bureaucracies
meant to limit and control
him, to manage him.
Of the project to restore
this man's intensity,
as Foucault put it,
Foucault himself said he
lacked the necessary talent.
He never wrote the book.
I regard this phantom project he proposed
as explicitly for us, the novelists.
If not to complete, to at least begin.
- [Emily] Thank you.
(audience applauding)
Caleb, you were gonna talk about,
I think a different kind of writing
from within prisons,
conversion narratives.
So I will turn things over to you.
- Thank you Emily, Rachel, Joy,
everyone who did the work
to organize this conference.
When I saw the the title for our panel,
"Literary History of
the Incarcerated Mind,"
that singular really stood
out to me, "the mind."
And since Peter mentioned
some kind of inspiration
for this conference coming
out of his prison teaching,
also in one of my own experiences
with prison teaching--
- [Audience Member] A
Little closer to mic?
- Sure.
Is that better?
Can you hear me?
So one of my own experiences
with prison teaching
has been kind of lingering
in my consciousness
as I prepared for this event.
And it was a conversation I
had with a student named Clyde
when I was teaching in
Cheshire Correctional Institute
with Wesleyan's prison program
before we had our own here at Yale.
And we were discussing
Frederick Douglass's
1845 narrative in that class.
And Clyde was, who's kind
of a leader, is Clyde here?
He's here at Yale as a fellow now.
He sort of interrupted the conversation
and he said, "You know,"
he'd been taking Wesleyan
classes for years at this point.
And he said, "You know,
people like you come in here,
they want us to read Douglass
and they want us to read Foucault,
and they wanna ask me
about my subjectivity."
And he said, "What I wanna know is
what about your subjectivity?"
And that resistance to
being seen as someone
whose subjectivity was
an object of curiosity
and an object of interest on
people who were coming in,
even presumably to be his teachers,
is something that I have really tried
to think about the sources of
and dwell with a little bit.
And I wanted to talk today
about a specific genre
that seems to me very central
to the long literary history
of imagining and attempting to understand
or give accounts of incarcerated minds.
And that is the conversion narrative,
specifically the Protestant
religious conversion narrative.
And some of my research
on the early decades
and the cultural history
of the US prison system
in the 18-teens, 20s, 30s, and 40s,
I recently came across
this very remarkable grave
in Canandaigua, New York.
It's a big monument with
a tall obelisk above it
and a weathered metal
plate inscribed on it.
And the text of the
inscription reads this way,
"Jacob Hodges, an African Negro
born in poverty and ignorance,
early tempted to sin by
designing and wicked men.
Once condemned as a felon,
converted by the grace of God in prison,
lived many years a converted
and useful Christian,
died February, 1842, in
the faith of the gospel
about 80 years of age."
This monument identifies
the man by his name
and by his race.
And then it tells very
briefly the story of his life.
It goes back to his childhood
in poverty and ignorance,
passes through the crisis of
his temptation and his sin.
Hodges, as it turned out,
was kind of conscripted by
conspirators to participate
in the murder of a White property holder
in Orange County, New York.
It recounts his religious
experience in prison,
and it confirms the lasting effects
of that religious experience.
When he was converted by
the grace of God in prison,
this grave marker says,
the change in his character
wasn't just a fleeting
kind of affectation.
It really turned him around for good
and he lived many years this
way in the faith of the gospel.
So these are the kind of elements
of a Protestant conversion narrative.
First his ignorance, then
his seduction, then his sin,
then judgment and suffering, conversion,
and this new more faithful
life that he lives out
for the rest of his days.
Above that congregationalist
or Anglo-Protestant conversion narrative,
there's this Egyptian
symbol, the obelisk, right?
And I learned a little bit about this
trying to understand it and
and learned that by the,
by about 1842 there were
a number of obelisks
in the North Atlantic metropoles.
And it would be just six years
later that construction began
on the most famous one
in the United States,
the Washington Monument.
So in 1842 in an upstate
New York village cemetery,
this is not exactly a shocking image,
but it's a sort of,
it is a symbol of a kind of
appropriation of an African form
into this Anglo-American
settler civilization.
The place is called Pioneer Cemetery.
So it seems plausible to me
that this particular symbol was chosen
partly because as a kind of testament
to the successful racial
assimilation of Jacob Hodges
into this upstate community
by way of his religious conversion,
or at least to the hope of a
kind of racial assimilation
in a post-Emancipation
era in New York state.
And then finally there's
the metal plate itself.
I mean obelisks are ancient.
Protestant conversion narratives go back
at least to early New England settlements
on this continent.
But that metal plate
is forged in a foundry
and it has forged bolts
that are securing it
into the base of this tomb.
And so in that way,
it's not only an ancient
or even an old fashioned Christian form,
but also this tomb is
very much an artifact
of the new industrial economy
that was taking shape in upstate New York,
and one of whose major
sites of development
was the contract operated
workshops of Auburn State Prison
where Jacob Hodges was
incarcerated for most of a decade.
So I take this grave to be
telling one person's story
by way the conversion narrative,
but also as a kind of
artifact of these three forces
that came together at
the foundational moment
of modern industrial prison discipline.
And those are evangelical religion,
conflicts and struggles over the question
of post-Emancipation racial assimilation.
So this is the time of arguments
about colonization
versus education efforts
to lift up the state's
growing free Black population,
upstate New York.
And also the industrial economy
that was very quickly
transforming the economy
of upstate and New York
with what historians
sometimes call the market
revolution and industrialization,
which involved a rapid transition
away from older systems,
not only of slavery,
but also of indenture and
apprenticeship toward wage labor
so that the laboring population
was suddenly much more mobile
and each worker much more on their own.
And many instances of discipline
that previously would've
been handled domestically,
that is by masters,
are now being outsourced to the state,
which is doing them in this,
doing labor discipline
and moral discipline
in the new institutions.
You can see, I think, why
a conversion narrative
would be useful to a prison system
that explained its project
in terms of rehabilitation.
It was aligned with the reformist program,
not with vengeance and not
even with mere incapacitation,
but with the promise
that people's characters
could be rehabilitated in prisons.
It was also aligned specifically
with religious liberty.
The chaplains who operated
in Auburn State Prison
were not paid by the state.
They were paid by
philanthropic organizations,
and so your religious education
in a place like Auburn
could be seen as voluntary,
not state imposed.
And we have much evangelical
activism to this day,
which understands itself to
be in favor of rehabilitation,
but not in favor of rehabilitation
under the direction of
state-appointed elites.
So those are the...
And you can also see, I think,
the kind of ideological work
that prison conversion
narratives would've done
in the 19th century and
perhaps still do today.
They give a kind of moral legitimacy
to large scale captivity
and compulsory discipline,
and specifically tend
to align incarceration,
not with re-enslavement,
not with violence,
but instead with a kind
of moral correction.
But over the past 200 years,
as you can probably imagine,
the conversion narrative
as a kind of template
for telling someone's life story
or telling the story of
someone's experience in prison
going through suffering,
has also been adapted to many other uses.
For criminal justice reformers,
the ideal of rehabilitation,
and in some cases the ideal
of a kind of conversion
or transformation of one's character,
is often held up as the ideal
against which other more abusive realities
and injustices can be measured.
So it can have this kind
of critical function
in relation to the way
that criminal justice
is actually being enforced.
It also has been taken up in
more militant and radical ways.
You can think about autobiographies
and even shorter pieces of
autobiographical prison writing
that talk about the author's conversion,
not to a kind of the docility
of a Christian conversion
and acceptance of the justice
of their own sentence,
but instead to a kind
of militant opposition
to the systems hat have
seized them, right?
We can think about conversions to Marxism,
conversions to radical Islam,
conversions to faiths and positions
that happen through the prison experience,
but that set the author
now against the system
that has condemned them.
For people like me who
work in literary studies
and cultural studies,
these documents have a real richness.
They are available to
humanist kinds of reading and criticism.
We may have a sense in reading them
that we've been able to recover
or at least acknowledge voices
against the silencing power of the state.
We might encounter real narratives
of psychological and spiritual vividness
in these personal accounts.
The traditional, the kind of irony
of the traditional conversion narrative
is that it was supposed to be your own
intensely sincere experience,
but it wasn't a real conversion narrative
unless it conformed
perfectly to the template
of the conversion narrative, right?
But people have, but of
course developed stories
about conversion that
have a lot of idiosyncrasy
and richness and
intensity and singularity.
We can read these texts
for moments in which they
seem to resist or subvert
or even just improvise
against what seems to be the script
that's been provided for them to perform,
and so locate moments of agency,
locate moments of subversion and so on.
It is a genre that has a long history then
and many uses and much richness.
At the same time, it has its limits
or certain ways of approaching
it can be limiting.
And specifically, one reason
I'm glad to be thinking here
with Rachel's account
of what novels can do
is that much of what she's just described
in terms of the sweep of a social world
is what falls away in
a conversion narrative.
The incarcerated mind, right?
The conversion narrative itself,
may be part of its ideological
function is to say,
hey, the prison isn't so bad.
It actually gave me this
opportunity to correct myself
and rehabilitate myself and so on.
But another part of its
ideological function is to say
here is one story.
One person's story, and
that's what prison is.
It's one person's story, right?
And so the large sweep and
scale of the catastrophe
may drop out of view
if we think about the
singularity of this voice.
How then do we scale up from
this one story to the mass,
to the system, to the structure?
I think this is a problem
in how we think about
conversion narratives,
and in some ways I think
it's a problem at the heart
of how much the humanities themselves
can say or do in relation
to these systems.
But what I've tried to
at least sketch out here,
at least at the beginning,
is ways of reading these not
only in order to acknowledge
and value the particular
stories that they tell,
but also to move out from them
into the scales and structures
of historical forces
that give them weight
and give them meaning.
And the three in particular
that seem resonant to me,
that seem almost to have
come out of frozenness
and reanimated themselves in our own time
are the three that I mentioned
shaping the tomb of Jacob
Hodges at the beginning.
We have a very active evangelical,
White evangelical movement
aligned with the politics
of harsh punishment in
our country right now,
just as they did in the
burned-over district
of upstate New York during the
Great Awakening of the 1840s.
We have a radical shift
and destabilization
of our economic system.
For them it was the
transition from indenture,
apprenticeship, and slavery
toward industrialism and wage labor.
For us, it is the other
side of de-industrialization
that's been analyzed by
Ruthie Wilson Gilmore
and many others as being
the economic context
within which this system takes shape.
And we have a kind of moral panic
about racialized migrant
laboring populations
just as they did in upstate
New York in the 1840s,
and conflicts over whether there will be
a kind of assimilation overseen
by White Christian nationalist authorities
or whether there can only be exclusion,
separation, and expulsion.
And reading for those political
forces is one way, I think,
we can both see the singularity
of the conversion narrative
and of the voice in it,
and also think about some
of the larger political
and cultural forces that give it its force
and give it its meaning
and toward which we have
to gain some leverage.
Thanks.
- [Emily] Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- [Emily] Can I hand it over to you?
- Yeah, sure.
- [Emily] Great.
- Okay, good morning.
Thank you. (clearing throat)
Excuse me, thank you, Rachel and Caleb.
It's really rich.
So I've got five minutes,
I'm gonna have to squash.
There's a lot in both of
your, you know, contributions,
and I started thinking, excuse me.
I started thinking of dichotomies,
and the possibility of what
could be synthesized, right?
So you have fiction, you have nonfiction,
you have this subject
gazing at the object,
meaning the incarcerated.
(coughing)
I also wanted to add the possibility
that there's the focus on the individual,
but there's also the collective
and the communal, right?
That whole communities can be decimated
and then reconstituted.
That fathers will meet
their sons incarcerated,
you know, mothers who have long terms
can meet their children.
Or we spoke about it last night,
give birth inside of these systems
and then have their child
removed and disappeared, right?
So I'm wondering how you
see the convergence, right,
as a conversion narrative, right?
So I mean, Caleb,
you laid out what we've inherited
and what we will leave our children.
Hopefully it will improve,
but you know, the odds don't
seems so great at the moment.
So Kathy Belew, who's at
University of Chicago,
has a text on how the White
supremacist underground
came above ground,
and these long wars that the
US had in the Middle East
actually professionalize
them as an army, right?
And so it's not just what
happens in the voting space.
It's also what happens with people
who I think you were pointing to
when you're talking about
this increasing animus
against migration, right?
From sites that have been devastated
by the over-consumption of water,
and, you know, environment devastation
done largely by the West.
So if there is a convergence,
what might that look like
as a political phenomena?
And also what are the possibilities
that as much as we emphasize morality,
we need a shared understanding
of political ethics, right?
So how we wanna be as moral people
is that we care about the incarcerated,
which is, you know,
and I really heard you when you said,
well, you know, people are saying,
well, why don't you do
nonfiction and be useful, right?
Which of course is a false dichotomy
because your work is abolitionist work.
And people who are incarcerated,
at least the few times I've
been able to be inside,
they are also writers and
authors and they read novels
and they write novels, they write poetry,
they write memoirs.
But I'm wondering, you know,
as academics and people in
this room are also writers,
to what extent do we have
a community of writers,
whatever genre we explore or, you know,
dabble in or become professionalized
in, are brilliant in,
that it actually constitutes
a political ethics
that can bring another kind
of conversion narrative
other than the evangelical reactionaries
that are on the rise?
And I'm not sure like that we've agreed
to even attempt that endeavor.
Like these are all peers.
The incarcerated writers
are our peers, right,
and our teachers.
And I wonder what would it take,
you know, to push forward with that?
And I just wanna give
a couple like specifics
'cause I know I like, I
have two minutes left.
So I was thinking of, you know,
you brought up Foucault.
And Foucault visited Attica.
And Foucault, also under the
encouragement of Jean Genet,
wrote a pamphlet that Gallimard published.
It was in French til
like a decade or so ago.
I think it was called "The Assassination"
or "The Masked Assassination,"
and he was talking about
George Jackson's death.
So this would be someone
who needed a conversion,
but it wasn't gonna be
into a certain kind of religiosity.
It was gonna be a conversion
to a certain kind of militancy
aligned with the Black Panther Party.
And I would argue that
the state and society
doesn't want those kind of conversions.
So if we...
I don't, you know, I can't, I mean,
I've got 60 seconds now.
But I'm really troubled
by the ethics of this.
Like what we don't want is
what will continue to manifest
because of the violence arrayed
against certain communities.
So do we have a tolerance
of interacting with what
we don't want, right?
To stitch together sort of
common political ethics.
So Jean Genet wrote the forward
to George Jackson's book
at the encouragement
of Fay Stender, who is an attorney.
You know, kind of recruited him.
You know, this White intellectual,
sort of like I want you to, you know,
my legal degree is from
the University Chicago.
You're Jean Genet.
I want you to do this for this
book that's very rebellious.
And he agreed to do that, right?
James Baldwin will write an
open letter for Angela Davis
when she's on trial,
and before increasingly the populations
can say we can embrace her.
We understand that she
has a certain kind of
innocence and legitimacy.
But there are people who are rebels
and there are people who are not innocent,
and they continue as our peers.
So if we were to recognize
that, what would we become?
And then how does that,
you know, subject-object,
you know, dichotomy become a synthesis
and the fiction-nonfiction can emerge
and too just like literary contributions
that would allow us to
have more strategies
and more tools for what we need to do?
- I love that, thank you.
I'm gonna add a little
bit to this discussion
'cause it's hitting so many
notes from my own work,
so I can't quite resist.
Caleb, you were talking
about the American mind,
and I think in...
Or I'm sorry, the incarcerated mind.
It could also be the American mind.
And I always pluralize words like that
because to me as a journalist,
one of the most difficult
aspects of my work
is figuring out how to use a story,
a narrative to say something
about this scaled up catastrophe.
And you know, Joy,
you're taking this in another direction.
Not just multiplicity,
but thinking of people as peers
as opposed to necessarily the
subject-object relationship.
And when you are a writer
who's not yourself incarcerated
and you're writing about other people,
there is this kind of
way in which they are,
if not the object in a,
you know, abstract way,
you are trying to understand their world.
You are not within it.
And I think the reason, to me,
that's so obvious for art or
novels or fiction or movies
about incarcerated people and environments
and the communities they're parts of
is that hopefully those
are things that move people
who are outside this self-enclosed world
that you were talking about, Rachel.
And so there's a parallel universe
that pulls in more
people's hearts and minds.
But the step to thinking
about people as peers
is a more radical and profound step
that I think, you know,
as a society we have,
we continue to fail at
almost all the time.
I've been thinking about it personally
because I wrote a story for
"The New York Times Magazine"
a couple years ago,
or actually a year and a half ago,
about a man named Yutico Briley,
who wrote to me from prison.
And he wrote a short,
but very clear letter.
I get a lot of mail from
incarcerated people.
Lots of lawyers and journalists
and even professors do.
And it's hard to know what to make
of this multiplicity of voices.
It can feel sort of overwhelming.
But this letter touched me
for a couple of reasons.
There was a claim of innocence
that Yutico made in it,
but he also said that he
was imprisoned for 60 years
for an armed robbery,
and nobody had been injured
in that armed robbery.
And so my initial response was to think,
well, that was so drastically unfair.
Such an example of excessive punishment,
which is something Dwayne Betts,
who unfortunately isn't
here with us today,
but something he talks and thinks
and has taught me a lot about.
So I reached out to Yutico.
We started corresponding through JPay,
the sort of corrupt for-profit service
that is what a lot of incarcerated people
are forced to rely on.
And Yutico was sort of
having to reel me in, right,
and interest me.
There was this way in which he stood to,
he had to figure out a way to
persuade me to care about him.
And then over the course of time
I got more involved in this case.
I ended up looking for a lawyer for him
'cause it was so clear
to me that what he needed
was a lawyer, not a
journalist at this moment.
That lawyer happened to be my sister.
So then this trying to
figure out, you know,
whether there was a
way to exonerate Yutico
years after he'd been incarcerated
became this kind of joint project.
And Yutico is a very charismatic person,
so his sort of personhood
was really important
to what we were working on.
And he was really in a
lot of ways he was driving
what was happening,
but also of course had kind
of limited agency necessarily.
So in the end he was
not guilty of this crime
he'd been convicted of,
and he was exonerated
in part because the community
in New Orleans changed.
The voters decided to elect
a new district attorney
and a new judge,
who were much more
interested in actual justice
than the people who'd preceded them.
And so Yutico got out of
prison, was exonerated.
It's now about a year and a half later,
and I started getting more mail
after my piece came out, not surprisingly,
and I couldn't bear to just
not respond to the letters
in the way that I had
tended to do in the past.
So I started a project here at Yale
in which law students
and I have been working
with these letters to create a database
that's on the Freedom Reads website
and is trying to amplify the
voices of incarcerated people.
And it's very much about a
kind of multiplicity of voices,
and hoping that, this is
something Dwayne says a lot,
that if people could
see and hear the voices
that we see and hear,
if you're in touch with
people on the inside,
that maybe that would create
the kind of energy for change
in radical form that we are still lacking.
It's not quite a peer relationship though.
And yet I have ended up having
exactly that relationship
with someone who's incarcerated
whose name is John J. Lennon,
who's a prison journalist
who Dwayne introduced me to.
And John and I have been
writing together a newsletter
for "The New York Times"
about some of these stories
that are coming in,
and it's really turned
into a collaboration.
I don't think I really
thought it through very much
when Dwayne proposed it.
I was sort of glad to feel like
maybe I was supporting John in some way,
but that is not the way the
relationship has developed.
John turns out to have
lots of ideas to offer,
but also incredible patience.
So we had this period over the summer
where my editors were not
really sure what shape
they wanted the first edition
of this newsletter to take,
and I was getting really impatient
with them and frustrated.
And John was the one who really kind of
saw through my frustration
and was able to say, you know what?
Like they are trying to make
this as good as it can be
and we need to take their feedback
and really incorporate it
and think about, you know,
why they're having us change course.
And he was by far the more mature one
in this interaction of the two of us,
which shouldn't have really surprised me,
and yet it really turned the
tables on my own assumptions
about who peers can be
and what those kinds of
relationships can be.
So I guess I'm telling this story
because it seems to me that
what we're hearing up here
is this sort of grappling with
what it is to tell stories,
to figure out a way how to
scale them up to a recognition
of the catastrophe you
were talking about, Caleb.
But then also figuring out this move
where we're not just sort
of bestowing attention.
We're also really seeing
people as individual humans
and as just like us,
just in a different self-enclosed world.
So that was a little bit
of a lot of thinking.
But I wonder, Rachel, if that
speaks to some of your work?
- Well, yeah.
I'm still thinking about
what Joy was saying.
Like so many incredibly
incisive points she made
that I immediately wanted to respond to
and then incorporate what
you just said, Emily.
But so back to Jean Genet
just for a quick second.
I'm so glad you mentioned him
because actually in that
incredibly damning article,
self-damning maybe,
piece that Kakutani wrote in 1981,
she quotes Joyce Carol Oates,
who says that actually Jack Henry Abbott
was not a real criminal
or an authentic criminal,
and she uses the word authentic,
because he seemed like somebody
who'd read a lot of Jean Genet.
And so she's desperate
to keep writers over here
and criminals over here,
and anybody who smells like literature
cannot come from the streets.
And it's just, it's
wonderfully transparent
or horribly transparent.
In my own experiences working
with people inside prison,
which I do separate from writing novels,
I have peers who are
serving life sentences.
In one case, somebody who's
serving two life sentences.
Meaning when she goes up for
parole after her 25 years,
if the parole board deems
her suitable for freedom,
then she can start her second sentence.
And a lot of these people are readers.
I've one friend in prison who told me that
the most popular book on
administrative segregation,
which is Chowchilla's version of solitary,
the most popular book is
"Malice" by Danielle Steele.
And I said, "That's a novel
about women in prison."
She goes, "Yeah."
And I quite ignorantly, this
was several years ago, said,
and I'm embarrassed to admit
this, but I think it's useful.
I said, "Why would you wanna read?
You guys are stuck in prison.
Why would you wanna read
a novel about prison?"
And she goes, "Rach, we
don't just wanna read novels
about your all's divorce or whatever."
She's like, "We wanna read
books about people like us."
And what she was doing was challenging me,
but also supporting me
because I wanted to write
this novel, "The Mars Room."
And she was like, you do
that, you write that novel.
I also, you know, I work
with people in prison
together on projects.
I used to be involved with
this organization Justice Now,
whose board of directors was comprised
entirely of people inside prison,
mostly serving very long sentences.
And the reason that was the case
was because the woman who
started that organization
actually got the Fay
Stender Award one year,
said to a friend of hers inside prison
bring me like shot callers.
Bring me the most influential
people in the whole prison.
And those are people who are
serving very long sentences
and then they were trained
in human rights work
to like each one teach one,
and teach, you know, the
signs of human rights abuses
to other people in prison.
Working with those people,
I am much more a student
than I am a teacher.
And I don't fool myself that
this is an equitable world.
I'm acutely aware of
these power differentials.
They can call me collect, I can
simply not answer the phone.
I cannot call them, et cetera.
I think that this work
is uneven and ongoing,
to answer that.
In terms of, maybe I misunderstand,
but you brought up morality.
And I thought this is such
an interesting word to use
in a world where the religion
and ideology of liberalism
is that liberalism as
a kind of universalism
is gonna hold up any person who wants it
and then can access the kind of freedom
that liberalism affords us.
Like consumer freedom.
This is not the case.
So then what do we do
with, if I understand it,
individual morality as opposed
to a collective ethics?
The last thing I just wanna say quickly
is listening to Caleb's talk,
I was reminded of what seems
to me a really terrible irony,
at least in California,
which is that maybe the only vestiges left
of the idea of a fundamentalist
conversion narrative
in the prisons that are managed
by the California
Department of Corrections
is that the Bible is the
one thing you can have
no matter what you've done in prison.
When you find yourself
in the jail of the prison
or the jail of the jail of the prison,
which would be to go to solitary
and leave your prison, that ad-seg,
and go to an ad-seg ad-seg prison,
they will never take away your Bible.
And it's almost as if they are saying,
and I only realize this
listening to him talk,
that those inside prison
who have messed up
are condemned to religion
in a way that the rest of us are not.
We can continue to shop and
lease cars and do this and that,
but they have to pray.
- What you're describing is the ongoing.
It's exactly continuous with
evangelical prison reform
in the 1820s whose project
was to mass print Bibles
and put one in every single cell.
When Jacob Hodges was released,
one of the reformers went and asked him
if he could have the prison
Bible that had converted,
that Hodges had had his conversion with.
And Hodges was like,
"No, you can't have it.
Why would you presume that
you can take this away from,
you know, this one thing?"
And after he died,
Hodges sent it to the Reform Society
and this minister, Louis Dwight,
used to go around holding up Hodges' Bible
as a kind of prop in his sermons.
It's an interesting thing
because Evangelicalism,
it was like the first mass
media religious movement
just as it has become like a televangelism
and internet phenomenon now.
But suddenly the mass printing gave,
like regressed back to
this fetish of the single,
the single object that
had converted Hodges.
(panelist speaking off mic)
Yeah, the aura comes back, yeah.
I wanted to say a little bit about
to Joy's great question
about what forms of community
are kind of broken
apart and reconstituted.
Sometimes when we describe criminalization
and incarceration as a tactic
of class war and race war,
the response to that is, oh,
but a lot of poor people
support harsh punishment.
Or a lot of people in the
Black community support,
want police to keep
them safe or something.
And the point is not people
with privilege and property
support harsh punishment
and everyone else doesn't.
It's that criminalization
and incarceration
and policing as the
only point of interface
with any kind of state
service divides, right?
It creates this division.
And in New York state
already in the 1840s,
the stone cutting masons at large
were saying we can't compete
with this incarcerated labor.
That's no-wage labor, and
it's creating a class division
within this emergent working
class in the era of wage labor,
and that is ongoing.
But it's also true that we see,
I mean, I think your point
about some conversions
are isolating and some are conversions
into a different solidarity
or into a different community
is really a meaningful one
that I didn't draw out
much in my presentation.
You know, often those of us who teach
learn from our students
that they've been going off to the block
and conducting seminars
on the same topics.
Not that they're transmitting
what I said about the text,
but that they're having their
own discussion about the text.
And some of that is coming back
to change our conversation in the room.
The kinds of,
the the kinds of small scale
connections and community
that get formed on those
long bus rides, you know,
out to the Central Valley or something
and then become networks of activism
that can link out and so on.
I think, and I really like the distinction
between a kind of moralism and an ethics.
For my part, I do become a little wary
when I hear a language of we
need a reckoning on this topic,
as if a kind, you know,
as if the spirit is gonna
sweep across the land
and people are gonna embrace
a new faith on justice.
To me, that is, that kind of talk is,
expresses in part a sense of dispossession
and no access to the real mechanisms
of how you change a political structure.
And so the idea of an
ethic that's more about,
well, people might
actually have many reasons
for being against this
or for being in solidarity
with each other,
and that there would be
a kind of lateral ethic
of mutual respect of what
brings people to the work
around a common project is the way that I,
that I would understand that difference
between a kind of, you know,
an awakening and a kind
of solidarity ethic.
You know this...
Well, I think, yeah, I
think that's what, that's...
I wanna give other
people some time to talk.
- So this is a half joke for
Rachel, as a former seminarian.
I'm praying it works,
but also I think it's interesting,
we've talked a lot about Christianity.
So a number of people that I know who...
Like so my work right, is political theory
and I work with radical,
you know, theorists,
but people who were in the
Panthers are now Muslims.
So their names are changed,
Dhoruba bin Wahad, Jalil
Muntaqim, Assata Shakur, right?
So there is something about
spirituality and religion,
and maybe because it is Islam that is,
it's also a counter to, you know,
a reactionary Christian state
or certain kind of dictates,
like you're saying the Bible is sacred.
You could, you know, that's your key.
You could carry it anywhere.
Quran maybe no.
If you're a Buddhist, you know,
maybe you have a little gray area.
I'm wondering to go back
to something I asked before
and I also wanna put on the table,
there's a prison strike
right now in Alabama, right?
And so we talk a lot about censorship
around critical race theory.
Like the banned books thing
that appears to be mushrooming,
you know, from the South and
then moving across the US.
I'm wondering if you have any thoughts
about how incarcerated
writers are censored
and how it's difficult for
them to get their works out,
particularly if they're
critical of the state itself?
'Cause we've never, we know that the state
has predatory strategies and a history.
The 13th Amendment legalizes
enslavement in prisons
or if you've been duly
convicted of a crime.
So that's kind of on the table.
And then the last thing,
and then I'll stop,
is the dichotomy between the privileged
imprisoned or prisoner
and then the one that is expendable.
So when Davis was on trial,
she had a co-defendant, Ruchell Magee,
and there was an online
celebration of his 82nd birthday.
He's still inside, right?
Because he didn't, he, you know,
one, he actually was in Marin County
and he was holding one of her guns, right?
But his argument is that he was a slave,
and all slaves have the
right to fugitivity.
Davis' position was
that she is not a slave,
she's a citizen.
And so she has the right
to the protection of law.
There are segments of the incarcerated
who see themselves as captives
through the filter of the 13th Amendment.
And so their writings will be
less likely to appear in public.
And so the public's
ability to protect them,
if, you know, like Stevie Wilson
who's a Black queer writer,
he's continuously thrown in the hole
because he's talking
about abuses by guards,
abuses by systems, right?
So I'm wondering about, you know,
the protective mechanism
that the author can offer
to the incarcerated?
- [Rachel] Can I?
- [Caleb] Yeah.
- Man, I mean we could
just, I wish, you know,
we don't have that much time,
and then you just raised
many important points,
but just a couple things
that come to mind.
(clearing throat)
Sorry to sound acerbic,
but the Marshall Project
is an organization that
was started by Bill Keller,
who used to be, was the editor
of "The New York Times."
And it's meant to be a project
about incarceration in America.
And when it was first started,
they had a kind of like
fundraising cocktail party
in Los Angeles and somebody invited me
even though I was not the
target audience of the party,
which was about raising money.
And I asked, "Are you
going to have a section
where you share the writing
of incarcerated people?"
And Bill Keller said,
"Well, this is not gonna be
prison poetry monthly."
And people went, "Ha, ha, ha, ha."
And I, you know, wanted to
gun down the entire crowd.
But so then the Marshall Project started,
and I did turn to it as a resource
for friends inside prison
who wanted an outlet for their writing
because of what they were doing
and they had a really,
you know, a big platform
and a lot of money behind it.
And one friend of mine's
work was published
in the Marshall Project twice,
and I had to be her interlocutor with them
because they didn't have a
JPay thing set up at the time.
And so she would send the pieces to me
and I would send them to them.
And I noticed that she was
always calling the editor Mister.
And I would have these
conversations with her,
"Don't call him Mr., you
know, he's merely your editor.
He's not a guard.
He is not your counselor in prison."
But it was just so hard for her
to get beyond these kinds of institutional
hierarchized sorts of exchanges.
Anyone free is like a Mr. or a Mrs.
So when her piece, her
first piece was published,
for the biography, the editor asked me,
can you supply a bio?
No, he didn't ask me can
you supply a biography?
He didn't say anything about the bio.
And I said, "Do you need
a bio for this writer?"
And he said, "Oh, for
the incarcerated writers,
we include their age,
the prison where they're incarcerated,
and the crime of which
they were convicted."
And I honestly saw a man
opening a woman's mouth
to count her teeth.
And so I just totally
freaked out and said,
you can't, you know?
But then I'm in this position,
do I wanna stop my friend
from being published in this magazine
or do I have to assent to their rules?
And I got into a big fight
with the Marshall Project
that is ongoing to this day,
but for that one thing he said,
"I just won't include a bio."
So she didn't get to be treated
with the normal courtesy with
which a writer was treated.
And at first I tried to use
kind of obfuscation and say,
oh, women don't like to
have their age mentioned
in their bio.
That's not the normal kind
of thing you would put.
I mean, it was like birthdate,
location, and crime.
So there are these outlets
that we're given as resources
to help our friends inside prison,
but we have to push
back against these idea
that they would be otherized
at every step of the way.
I don't know if that speaks
to some of what you're saying,
but that's what came to mind.
- I just have a short update
'cause I was talking with John Lennon
about this very issue recently.
He's been, he has been a contributor
to the Marshall Project,
and your advocacy, I think,
had some effect, Rachel,
although I think he and other
people have continued it.
So he wound up as an
advisor to what is, I think,
and I don't work at the Marshall Project,
so if other people have other information
maybe we can add that
during the questions.
But he became an advisor to what I think
has become a sort of regular
contributor feature part
of the publication,
which is voices from
people who are incarcerated
and submissions and
essays they've written.
And he was saying that his battle
was to get those names onto the masthead
so that there would be
this kind of, you know,
real recognition of the
contributions they were making.
Anyway, I just had to
add that little update.
- [Rachel] No, please.
- It's really interesting.
And, you know, reducing people to their,
especially deciding that the
crime of their conviction
has to be the kind of tagline
when that's not something
they're choosing is,
yeah, kind of amazing,
and I guess also not.
Caleb?
- Yeah, well, I wanted to
give at least a mention
to Joy's volume, "The New Abolitionist,"
which is, has this work
that she's describing,
and encourage people to read
the writers that are in that.
I also wanna tell a little
bit about my experience
in discussing the 1858 prison memoir,
"The Life and the Adventures
of a Haunted Convict,"
which Joy wrote an incredible essay about
for "Boston Review."
That's kind of how we
first got to be in touch.
But Reed wrote a retrospective memoir
of his life in the 1850s.
And as I traveled around with that
and describing his life
and the conditions,
he was also at Auburn State Prison
that I've just been describing,
which was the birthplace of
the sort of penal servitude
that did eventually get
enshrined in the 13th Amendment.
That is, it was Northern
industrial penal servitude
that was for which an exception was made
that then came to be exploited
by the Southern states in
that re-enslavement project
because Auburn could not have operated
without this unwaged
labor in its workshops.
Anyway, the people,
as I discussed Reed and
his life story, people,
this goes back also the
question of genre or fiction
and nonfiction kinds of narrative.
The crowds were very deeply
preset with two expectations.
One: That his book was a diary or journal
rather than a retrospectively
crafted narrative of his life.
So they wanted the kind of
access to the raw experience
unmanipulated by art somehow.
And two: That he was innocent.
Neither of which was the case.
He fully, he described his
participation in crimes
and never, I mean,
he had a kind of protest
against the entire system,
but on the specific grounds
of his own, you know,
of the accusation and sentencing
there wasn't a disagreement.
And so that does seem to me
to speak to what you're saying
about what kinds of stories people expect
and are ready to endorse.
And this question of innocence
that you raised before
and what kinds they don't want to hear
or they don't want to think
of as being, you know,
on their side or politically aligned with.
I think that it also...
And so there are truths
that people don't want told
in this writing.
But the thing about the
wanting it to be a diary
also suggests another kind of
pressure that's alongside that
in some awkward ways,
which is that incarcerated
writers are only
supposed to talk about their
own experience as such.
And so there's a kind of like
we're not coming to them
for their poetry or whatever, right?
There's the this isn't,
I don't want your artistry, you know?
I want the kind of auto
ethnographic truth of this.
And Reed has an amazing moment in his book
where he talks about being asked
by a group of kind of anti-slavery,
wealthy White liberals
to recite some abolitionist
poetry for them, which he does.
And they're moved to tears.
He recites a poem by the British
anti-slavery poet, William Cooper.
They give him money, they
offer to support his education.
And then a kind of aside
to the reader, he says,
"I wonder what they would've said
if I recited some outlaw ballads instead?"
He's very sophisticated
about what kind of sympathy
is available to him,
what kind of charity case
he's being asked to play
in that situation,
and what the kind of like
White racial liberalism
of that economy is.
And that he carves out
for him space for himself.
To think of himself as someone
who could deploy many genres,
as an artist who's capable
of many kinds of storytelling
and who could confront them with something
that wouldn't be so readily acceptable.
You know, as a scholar of 19th century,
I'm routing a lot of my answers
back through this historical stuff,
but I do think that there
is some continuity there.
I would say there's this double
bind of tell us the truth,
but not too much, right?
- And I think, Joy, that
speaks to the question
you were asking about prisoners
who are writing a more 13th
Amendment-based challenge
to their incarceration.
And I wonder if that for you
brings up any other questions
about just like the limits of
this kind of communication?
I mean, are we, we as
a, obviously, you know,
the people who are in charge
of the prison environment
have an enormous amount of control
over what comes out
unless people are able to
smuggle images and writings out.
And if you wanna put
your name on something
that you're writing, then the, you know,
the smuggling avenue is you can do it,
but then you're gonna be
punished for it, right?
And so we're, there,
so I guess I'm wondering about two things.
So there is this real
cost that someone like,
sorry, I've forgotten the name
of the person you were referencing before
who was not able to get his writings out
or who's being put into--
- [Joy] Stevie Wilson.
- Stevie Wilson?
- [Joy] Some of his work is out,
but he's continuously harassed.
- Yes, so he's having
this particular dilemma
of wanting to be the named author
in the work he's producing
because it's his creative
mind that's producing it.
It's his work.
It should have that recognition.
But there's this incredibly
clear cost to bear.
So that's one sort of very
contemporary manifestation,
I think, of the limitations
that Caleb was talking about.
And then we are having this moment
where prisons are losing control
over some of the particularly photographs
and even videos that are coming
out of these environments
because of the, you
know, cell phone culture
in which people are able
to document their worlds.
And in the last several months,
"The New York Times" other publications
have run these incredibly
disturbing set of photos
and images that, you know,
people within the walls took to document
and show that they were happening.
And the reason those images can come out
with maybe a little more safety
for the people producing them
is that they're anonymous.
And so their power is, doesn't,
you don't get to claim the
ownership and authorship of it.
Anyway, I just was
thinking about those things
as you were talking.
- Yeah, so two quick things.
The reason why, Caleb, I
got into anthologizing,
I mean, I said it elsewhere,
is that I was asked by
Davis to do a prototype
for critical resistance,
and I did at CU Boulder, Colorado,
and then anthologized, you know,
the academics and the
intellectuals who were there.
And I agreed with the
press or asked the press
to send 50 copies inside.
And so I was given a list
of incarcerated people,
including people who'd
been in the Panther Party.
And so one person who'd been
in the Party wrote back.
Again, I say, you know,
it's kind of a joke on me.
You know, I thought I was being helpful.
That the book wasn't, he
didn't say it wasn't that good,
he just said thank you.
But you know, it doesn't really reflect
the conditions inside
of long-term detainees,
particularly those who
came in as political
because they have surplus torture.
'Cause the point is like we
don't just wanna break you.
We wanna break your
connection to these ideas
that make you think you could
take on the state, right?
And so when I went to Brown from there,
all I did was anthologize, right?
But also people weren't ready
for it so I left eventually.
But when I was writing,
it could be the Barrigans who were,
you know, pacifists.
Like Daniel, I can't remember.
One of them had cancer and died inside.
So I think it was Philip or Daniel.
I'm sorry, I keep mixing up the brothers.
They're Catholics who were
against the war in Vietnam.
They were Catholic priests,
and then one of them
left the church, right?
He was a contributor, right?
And but then you get letters
back, so the consequences.
You get the letters back
from the prison officials
that you're trending
towards in legal behavior
by trying to get information
from the incarcerated
about their perspective and politics.
You get pushback from
the university itself
'cause they're not ready for conferences
where former like Weather
Underground, you know,
Laura Whitehorn or something
come to campus and speak.
Like that was prohibited 20 years ago.
Now it's okay.
So then one of the things
that comes into my mind,
I mean, maybe like I should take more naps
and not think this much,
but it seems like what you couldn't do
20 years ago with rebels, you can do now.
I have former students.
When I was at Brown I was
teaching courses on the Panthers
who, you know, they're writers now.
They're doing a book or
other people are doing books
on George Jackson.
I could barely teach
George Jackson at Brown.
I mean my students went
on a verbal strike.
They sat in the class for two
hours and didn't say anything
'cause I assigned George
Jackson's "Soledad Brother"
and Frank Wilderson in the
beginning of his writings
on Afro-pessimism, right?
And it was, you know, they were
clever, they were brilliant,
they were ethically committed.
But it was, I think this
is what you were saying,
there's certain truths
that nobody wants to hear.
It's not even that they're inconvenient.
They're incompatible with who we are.
But now there's more compatibility.
And so I'm wondering if they're
turning into commodities?
If past rebels are now the
commodities of the 21st century?
And if we're going down that road,
then what is rebellion
against a proto fascist state,
which the prison already is?
You're just waiting for prison
culture, which is already,
you know, it's a parallel
mirror, a distorted one,
of increasingly what happens
at the borders, you know,
when you shoot people
coming over, you know,
'cause they're trying to
flee, you know, devastation.
And increasingly what's happening
in different sectors of society,
you know, Buffalo, Uvalde.
So I mean, these are
way too big questions.
They're giving me a headache,
but they're constant and I
don't live the conditions.
There are people who live the
conditions of severe violence
who are thinking all the time.
And then I think about it as an ally,
but I'm not sure how
steady my bridge is over
and I have no intention of
being implicated in anything
so that I lose my
privilege or my standing.
So those are some of...
Like that's what I meant about the ethics.
I'll say I'm a good person
so I have personal morality.
What my political ethics
are, they continue to shift.
I mean, one last thing is Kevin Johnson
is supposed to be executed
in Missouri next month
on November 29th.
And so people have asked us to help,
but you know, one, I don't
think, it's Missouri.
I don't think he can stop this.
But then what could be
said about his writings
so that we remember him if
we can't keep him alive?
And I think that's just
the basic bare minimum
that people make.
Those are their basic requests.
- We have a few more minutes.
I wonder if there's anyone in the audience
with a question they are
interested in asking?
I know it's always hard
to be the first person
who asks a question, but it
looks like I have some takers.
Peter, I feel like your hand is up.
You get the first question.
(Emily laughing)
- [Peter] I was very struck
by all sorts of things,
but by Rachel's phrase
about being condemned to
religion and the Bible.
I was struck by Rachel's phrase
of being condemned to religion.
The only book you can take into solitary
is the Bible essentially,
which aligns with the conversion narrative
that Caleb was talking about.
I was thinking back to an ancient genre
I think starts in the 17th
century of the Newgate biography,
where the Ordinary of Newgate,
who was the chaplain of
a big prison in London,
took confessions and autobiographies
from convicts who were about to be hung.
And he would literally stand
at the foot of the gallows
and take their confessions
and then he'd write them up
and publish them and
sell them for sixpence.
And he made a handsome
supplement to his salary
by doing this.
So this is the moment of truth, right,
in which they have to
express Christian thoughts,
but it makes them,
it gives them a kind of
posthumous glory in infamy
because they're supposed
to detail all their crimes,
but then tell how their
crimes led to their moment
of repentance at the foot
of the gallows and so on.
So there's some unhealthy
connection here, it seem to me,
to conversion, infamy, and publicity,
and profit of course
'cause he's making a good profit at this.
You talked about Vautrin,
Balzac's great criminal,
and there's this wonderful moment
when he converts to the police.
And what he essentially says
is there's no difference
between cops and robbers.
There's just two faces of the same thing.
- Can I?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Yeah, listening to you talk, Peter,
I was thinking also
about Joy's referencing
of the death penalty.
So like in this version where
you're allowed to confess
or forced to confess right before you go,
unfortunately I can't remember
the name of the person,
but somebody was executed
just a couple weeks ago
and the last line of the article was
he said nothing when
offered a final comment,
you know, before they,
I can't remember if he
died by electrocution
or by injection.
One of those two methods.
(audience member speaking off mic)
Okay, thank you very much.
Joe Nathan James.
There was another execution
last summer, I believe.
Unfortunately also, look,
I'm nervous up here.
I don't remember the name
of that person either.
But what the odd thing that I remember
about this other execution
is that the journalist who
was sent to report on it
was told by the guards that
her skirt was not long enough
and that it needed to
be exactly at the knee
and not one inch above it.
I believe it was half
an inch above her knee.
And so one of the other,
one of the lawyers who was
gonna be at that execution
loaned her from the trunk of his car
a pair of fishing hip waders,
which she was allowed to
wear into this execution.
The reason I bring this up
is that it just speaks to the absurdity
of the bureaucratic apparatus
that attends to matters of life
and death involving people.
I think about that a
lot, how strange that is.
I guess finally, maybe I just wanna add
that these conversions,
that these confessions, excuse me,
were sold, according to Peter,
is interesting to me because it also maybe
reminds me of a point
that maybe I keep coming
back to here this morning
about some desperate need on
the part of a free citizenry
or those who manage a free citizenry
to keep separate those who need to confess
from those who might possess a confession
almost as a talismanic reminder
that they themselves will not
be entangled in that process.
- [Audience Member] He has
this beautiful passage in this
and remarks on Marx from
'78 where he says, well,
of course all of my work has
always been fiction, right?
How could you not do fiction?
My historical work was fiction.
Of course historical facts,
you can check them all.
You can do the kind of
fact-checking for that work
and for social scientific work,
but threading it together,
sewing it together, right,
and what you do with it is
always an act of fiction.
And in part we aren't
willing, I mean, that's true.
Our nonfiction is fiction, our
social sciences are fiction,
but we're not willing
in part to accept that
because as academics we need
to protect ourselves from that,
from that cut.
But in truth, it's true
of journalism as well.
Everything is fiction,
and what that means is that everything
is a political engagement.
- Yes, why don't you have the last word
'cause I wanna be respectful of the time.
I'll close things off.
- Oh no, dear.
- No, no, sorry,
- I'll be really--
- I didn't mean to intimidate you, go.
- Well I love what you said,
but I also fear that maybe like fiction
is a kind of dirty word there
because it suggests a straying from truth.
Although you probably meant something
much more nuanced than that.
But I would say like
fiction to me in a way
is actually sort of,
back to your question,
is separate from or safe
from or protected from
in a sense the political
because the writer herself,
when she embarks on the
project of reflecting the world
through the grand and
hallucinatory mythical envelope
that we call the novel and
started, you know, 200 years ago,
when she embarks on that project,
she does not already have
an idea or an argument
of what the problem is
nor what the solution is,
and rather wants to reflect
reality in its granular detail
to the best of her ability.
So in that sense, if she has
somebody who's in prison,
if they're in prison in California,
probably they actually did the thing
that they were convicted of
and she's not going for what
the reader would like to hear,
which is that this person
is in fact innocent.
And she's gonna need to be able to
ensnare some of the
absurdity of the institution.
Like they give you a
handbook that's 30 pages
and then they give you
a guide to the handbook
that's 140 pages and they
want you to read both.
And then I guess just,
well, I don't wanna close,
so why don't you.
I just wanted to say that I do think
that I see the novel as
not necessarily political.
That doesn't mean that I'm not political.
I spent two years
writing a very long piece
about prison abolition for
"The New York Times Magazine."
So that's like a different set of tools
that I use on occasion,
but it's not the novel.
So I just want...
- [Joy] Can we say--
- [Emily] Yes, please.
- Yeah, so again, like thanks everybody,
but I do wanna echo what's been said.
I think the politics are,
that's the stumbling block.
And also, you know, I believe
in emotional intelligence.
And so if you accept the politics,
then you accept certain layers of trauma
even if it's secondary or
tertiary 'cause you're not inside.
And I think that also
can sometimes inhibit
whether or not we will
walk closer to politics
that are not popular.
So to shorten, I would
say I create two personas.
I do the political work.
I use the academy to pay for me,
you know, my family and health insurance.
And then I write theory as an academic.
I do the anthologies as a side gig,
which is where my heart is.
And that's the balance.
If you wanna call me a writer,
you know, I'm definitely an academic,
but anything I edit is because
there's a relationship.
Like all the relationships
that you expressed,
we all have them.
It's to show up to the relationship,
which then becomes a form of politics.
- That seems like an
excellent note to close on.
I feel like there's so many ideas
which we can spend the day unpacking.
Thank you so much,
Rachel and Caleb and Joy.
Thank you.
(audience and panelists applauding)
(light music)